there's some groups that I it's clear
from you know how I'm talking to them
that I I'm trying to sort of poke holes
in what they're saying but no I don't go
try to pick on people you know if
anything I try to understand people yeah
you know because picking on people is
really easy like anything that Society
sees is weird like furries or flat
earthers it's very easy to show up point
fingers make fun of them ask them weird
questions but when you ask the why or
how did you end up like this is when it
gets really interesting because you get
to just follow that why infinitely so
you get to the core of what drove them
to The Fringe and that's the [ __ ] that
fascinates me yeah that it's always the
same
what is it just Community
loneliness isolation
being ostracized by the traditional
group that they were around
online Echo Chambers loneliness personal
failure personal aspirations
common themes like old school [ __ ]
um yeah those are tropes that have been
around forever huh yeah that's what it
comes back to what does tropes mean does
that make any sense that makes sense all
right I'll take it oh it also comes back
to the Jews a lot really yeah because
they started it no like hella people
don't like Jews oh yeah Kanye was
talking about that
do you think that many people don't like
you I think it's
I mean I think it's
because Woody Kanye they were getting on
Kanye
I mean he's been saying some horrible
[ __ ] yeah you know that Kanye [ __ ] is
sad but do you think people should just
be up but should he be shut down from
saying stuff or he can just say I guess
people are going to say whatever they
want if he says I'm about to go Defcon 3
on the Jews and he's telling his
audience that like
um yeah uh Hollywood music is totally
controlled by Jews like it is true that
there is like highly influential Jewish
people in Hollywood but it's controlled
by money people bro capitalists of all
shapes and sizes and they're not loyal
to each other
but you know you think that that those
type that those that money people aren't
loyal to each other I mean in a sense of
collaboration but [ __ ] they're all
trying to race to the top that's how
it's working and the idea there's some
sort of cohesion there it's not really
true I mean like there is collaboration
but like what Kanye is talking about is
being exploited by you know predatory uh
recording I mean uh uh record companies
and [ __ ] like that and labels that's a
real thing the media and be invading his
life you know TMZ showing him to his
house at three o'clock in the morning
and asking him about his mental health
like every element of his private life
being publicized by media Outlets that's
a real thing right and so it's like he's
so close to talking about that but then
he is obviously someone in his ear being
like it's it's all about the Jews and
he's like and then my Jewish personal
trainer it's it's sad a lot of people
don't even know that they're being
anti-semitic and I also think the phrase
anti-semitic it's so overused yeah
people say it's tough because you can't
even sometimes it feels you can't even
say the word Jew or Jewish and you're
sudden like this person's anti-semitic
it's like well you could say black or
white or Christian or you know Muslims
or Slims some people call them yeah
but I'm just saying conspiracy thought
the idea that like every anomaly and
everything that goes a little bit weird
is not a result of human error it's a
calculated deep State plot every sort of
loophole there's loopholes in everyone's
reporting and everything has everything
goes wrong people think the CIA is doing
all this crazy [ __ ] they tried to kill
Castro and Cuba like 45 times the CIA
can't pull off anything correctly our
government can't do anything right yeah
yes I know people think they're capable
of these massive like mind control
conspiracies I was like The Wider the
roads look like that
I just don't get how people think that
that this all-powerful deep State can
manipulate and control the entire planet
yeah that's true if you can't even get
me from like Saint George to El Paso
yeah then how are you gonna get me from
like uh the aliens to
um you know to the Octagon right people
are bad at secrets too man they have
people are bad at secrets that's a good
point I always think that a lot about
Secrets like why if somebody knew
something on their deathbed why are they
going to hold on to it especially
anymore I could see 50 years ago
when there was this more like loyalism
to America too like we are this thing
like people I felt like had bought into
like we are this text this thread this
woven blanket but now it seems like we
are
the like P that's that's disappearing
yeah like if they told Trump about the
aliens
he would tell in a half hour he would
[ __ ] tell us yeah he'd be like I will
not be you know a puppet of the CIA yeah
and there's a spacecraft below the White
House
it's been there for 30 years it's not
what he sounds like right that's how he
would say it yeah it is yeah totally
true but and that's why I don't think
they could get all these pilots and
people that have died over the years
that I don't think they could get any of
those people to keep a secret anymore do
you think no somebody would make a tick
tock at a half hour before they're dead
like my dad just told me this yeah it'll
be the kids of these uh Area 51 people
yeah we're like so my dad just dropped
the bomb on me like all that [ __ ]
Area 51 is so sick dude yeah have you
been over there I tried to go I went to
the raid of Area 51 in 2019 one of my
first I think I remember that things
and it was a letdown huh the only guy
who got arrested was this like recently
divorced father of three who was in like
a he was sleeping in the back of his
Subaru next to our RV and he was like
they're [ __ ] in there and I'm going
and he tried to storm it by himself and
he got like you know
machine guns in his face wow yeah
dang do you think did you get the
feeling when you were there that they're
holding something no I think they're
just you know experimenting with drones
why would it be Area 51 like there's
merch along the whole highway saying
those aliens there yeah they would have
moved him by now through a different
black box site
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one